hi everyone this is Jerry this is a game
from the 1972 World Chess Championship
between Bobby Fischer and Boris Spassky
the round 10 game Fischer had the white
pieces and opened with e4 best buy test
as he would say
Spassky plays e5 Knight f3 knight c6 and
Bishop to b5 so this indicates the
reuleaux PES or spanish game pressure on
the knight in direct pressure on the
pawn I'll just be showing some
alternative variations this is there's a
lot to know what the real o PES there's
a lot of theory on it I'll just be
touching on some what-ifs in the game we
saw a6
but what if Knight f6 pressure against
efore we could see white simply castling
in black opting to go for the Berlin
defense grabbing on e4 and the following
sequence of moves coming about where the
end result looking on the black side and
blacks deficiencies is that the black
king is uncatted and has a little messed
up pawn structure but as compensation
has the bishop pair in an open position
which is usually an asset so that's a
little trade off that would occur from
that position but we don't see that but
instead a 6 chases the bishop back to a4
one other quick note if you try to grab
this pond like this
Queen d4 is played these two are hit the
pond will be regained so that's why we
see Bishop back and now Knight f6
hitting e4 white simply ignores that
threat and castles in this game Bishop
e7 was played but again what if Knight
takes pawn
this indicates the tirage variation can
this pawn be taken without black getting
killed well the answer is no but you
have to know how to react to that sort
of move d4 to just try and open up a
position open up this position at a
moment where White is ahead and
development and the black King has yet
to castle this a 5 is really going to
come into play in this sort of variation
b5 Bishop b3 and now an important point
in this position as black you can't be
greedy you can't
go ahead and grab pons like this that'll
be met with rookie one and you're in an
uncomfortable pin how to really meet
this threat against your night which is
unprotected and pinned d5 could be met
sharply with Knight c3 and if you grab
my knight I'm going to grab the bishop
and for those of you who are jujitsu
fans you'll know that black from this
position will be tapping out very
shortly these two Knights are hit
directly this rook is hit indirectly all
by just one white piece and this Knight
is really just doomed it's really caught
in a crossfire hit by both the bishop
and rook so it's just bad news for black
from this position not to be recommended
going into this specific variation
however from this point right here
instead of taking the pawn we could see
simply d5 a much better response opting
to allow the bishop come to come to this
e six square as well as allow this pawn
to support this efore Knight after pawn
takes pawn just to summarize it very
briefly the material has been restored
and it's just much more playable
position for sure we don't see this we
don't see the tirage variation but
instead black ops for Bishop to e7 more
development and it is at this point that
black is maybe getting ready to really
grab that pun and hang on to it so only
at this point here does white choose to
go ahead and defend this pawn what's
interesting to note is that there are
other ways to go ahead and watch over
efore you could play d3 watches over
equally for or you could play Knight c3
both of these outlined moves that I have
in blue watch over this efore punch so
why aren't they played in the Rue Lopez
it's important for you to know what sort
of plan to implement what sort of
middlegame strategy should you try to
undertake knowing this thing will allow
you to know why rook to e1 is the
preferred move from such a position here
is what you want to do as white you want
to make a move like rook or excuse me
pawn to c3 followed by pawned
or you want to establish two pawns in
the center on these two specific squares
and maintain them on those two squares
for as long as you can and I emphasize
maintain for a very important reason
which I will get to later c3 is played
for a couple of reasons again to support
this d4 advance as well as provide a
cubbyhole for this bishop on the c2
Square and taking that into account if
that's what we want to do it stands to
reason that's that's why we shouldn't
make a move like Knight to c3 because we
want to have our pawn here and we don't
play pawn to d3 because we don't want
this pawn to play the role of a
defensive piece we want it to have its
aspirations are to get to d4 where it is
an aggressive piece putting pressure on
this 'if I've pun so with that in mind
that's why we're seeing the move rook to
e1 one additional benefit of this rook
move to e1 is that f1 is vacated so that
this sort of knight type of maneuver is
possible it's often the case that in
this opening the position will close up
when that occurs this sort of well
maneuvering type type of moves just in
general are more likely to occur and so
you could see the knight take this sort
of journey where starts at b1 of course
it ends up on g3 with its ideal square
focusing on this f5 point a soft point
in the black position so those are some
things to be aware of this is why we're
playing rook here because we want to
take into account what White's plan is
going to be and we're also vacating f1
for our B one night at this point white
is actually getting ready to go ahead
and chop on c6 and then on e5 and simply
be up upon if black castles at this
point we could just go ahead and go for
this and notice how this move here Queen
d4 it's not the same white has clearly
done some more development prior to
grabbing the pawn there's no Queen takes
pawn from this variation the rook is of
course watching over it so after rook to
e1 now we see this pawn to b5 M
chasing the Bishop to b3 and now black
ops 2 place d6 what's interesting to me
is why d6 is played here opposed to just
castling castling will allow black to at
least consider going into the marshall
attack
for example if c3 is played here black
could you know if you're an aggressive
player as black you could be making this
pawn to d5 move giving up upon in
exchange for pressure against the white
king these are the moves that you would
see played c6 move like Bishop d6 the
Queen could jet out to h4 to try and do
some some pawn move for white try to try
to do some sort of pawn advance which
creates a weakness against a white King
which is lacking defensive pieces or
specifically look at the Queen side just
take a quick glance none of them have
been moved so white is lagging and
development so that's really where a lot
of the compensation lies from such a
variation we're not seeing this but
again that's just something that kind of
interests me here after Bishop b3 why
not just simply castle and at least
reserve the option to play d6 or d5 but
nevertheless what we see is just d6 here
and now c3 and only then Castle so
keeping in mind what we want to do we
want to play this d4 move however we
don't want to play it just yet and
there's this a big reason why if we play
d4 right now what black could do is play
Bishop g4 and the word that I was
previously emphasizing is this word
maintained not only do we want to
establish two pawns on d4 and e4 but we
want to be able to maintain them there
for as long as we can there's a big
reason for this and it's because this
pawn on d4 is the one who could really
change the pawn structure whenever it
wants it could capture on e4 or could
push forward or not let me let me just
GUP it could capture on after Bishop g4
could capture on e5 open up the position
or it could opt to play d5 and close up
the position being in that sort of setup
where you have the option to really
change the pawn structure to open the
position up or to close the position
really makes a big deal because if
you're for as long as you keep black
guessing what you're going to do that's
really it's very difficult for black to
meet those sorts of ideas you know will
white open up the position is black
enough or is white going to close up the
position we really want to keep black
guessing for as long as we can but if we
play d4 right away like this Bishop g4
will do what's referred to as resolve
this tension in the center this tension
cannot be maintained because of the
pressure that's now being placed on the
white position or specifically this
knight on f3 is a critical defender of
this d4 square and with this bishop now
getting ready to not only take this
Knight for example let me just say let
play a nothing type of mode of a3 is
played if Bishop takes Knight we can't
recapture with the Queen because we're
going to lose on d4 and if we capture
like this well notice how we've weakened
our own King side structure so in other
words it's important to insert this move
right here for white instead of d4 right
away we want to play h3 to prevent this
bishop from coming here because again
not only do we want to establish pawns
here in the center we but we want to
maintain them there for as long as we
can so Knight b8 seems a bit awkward
that goes into what's what's known as
the Brier variation Knight to b8 its
intention is to reposition itself on
this d7 square have the Knights
connected and also it allows for this c5
advance so notice for as long as the
night is on c6 this pawn can of course
not move at all so the knight move
allows this pawn on c7 to advance where
it could then
meet this you know challenge this pond
that white is going to be placing on d4
very soon one other variation black
could go for Knight a5 and Bishop here
followed by c5 we could see d4 Queen c7
this is another way to go about things
but we're not seeing that instead the
Brier variation Knight b8 followed by
Knight B to d7 will be in effect and
only now d4 so finally we've made all
the prep moves necessary C 3 H 3 and
only now d4 Knight B to d7 essentially
developing move right under developing
that we have to get it back into play
Knight B to d2 and Bishop to b7 noticed
how by the putting pressure immediately
on this point right here Black is
restraining this d2 night I was
mentioning earlier that this night would
like to get to f1 maybe g3 but we can't
do that just yet that pond will fall so
by putting pressure on the white center
we stop this sort of maneuver Bishop
back to C 2 lenses a supporter of this
efore point and also allows this pun to
come to be for white is anticipating
that black will be playing c5 so white
wants to get this B pun involved in the
fight for control of the center rook e8
getting ready to tuck the bishop here
where the rook would then add potential
pressure against this eforp on b4 Bishop
back allows again the rook to see this
pawn here and now we see a for again a
move like Knight to f1 can't be played
because after capture this pawn is hit
three times and will be one next so
Knight to f1 is out instead we see on to
a for striking at this pawn this rook
pawn is hitting a knight pawn and this a
file could potentially open up on
White's terms Knight b6 looks to resolve
this tension and Fischer ops to simply
play a 5:1 other alternative you know
white could go ahead and capture like
this but I think black
be the side that's in a better position
to cope with the tension that is now
going on between these two Brooks black
can simply maybe make a move like rook
or Queen d7 and then the rooks would be
in direct contact with one another for
example Bishop b2 Queen here these rooks
are in direct contact with one another
the white queen you know is interfering
with these rooks for the moment and you
may very well see maybe a move like
Knight to a4
costing or causing maybe white some
problems since it would be hitting this
Bishop and pawn right here you may very
well see white having to give this
bishop up for the night
so that's why we're maybe not seeing
this pawn exchange right here in this
position but instead a 5 if the knight
goes here that'll just run into the loss
of pawn so a 5 takes the knight back to
d7 so not a it may seem insignificant
you know but the knight coming to b6
a5 and then the knight going back to be
set back to d7 it really its main
purpose was just to resolve the tension
that was going on between those two
pawns Bishop b2 gets a the last minor
piece involved and it looks a little bit
awkwardly placed because it's just
staring at its own pun but in
anticipation of this advance here soon
enough this Bishop will be able to see
the black position a little bit more
clearly so Queen b8 an interesting move
what's its intention to watch over this
'if I've pun in a very indirect way
there's some more work that needs to be
done before the Queen is watching over a
5 directly this pond will have to move
and this this pawn on d6 will have to
move but these are the this is the idea
that's in mind with this Queen b8
maneuver rook to b1 a little bit of an
awkward move what is its purpose to
watch over this bishop in anticipation
of what black will be wanting to do what
does black want to do in this position
wants to get this c7 pun involved if
black you know doesn't make that sort of
move you know what more really is there
in the position so
what we do see is c-5 we have a series
of exchanges and soon enough this Bishop
which look dumb on b2 springs to life we
have a bunch of exchanges going on on e5
to the Queen recaptures on to c4 so what
was the purpose of rook b1 watch over
this Bishop so it's protected and this
c4 move could come about the queen is
now hit queen f4 and now the bishop
simply grabs this knight not sure what
else could be played here if pawn takes
pawn that could run into some trouble
with maybe that this this sort of pin
the knight is hit once maybe maybe
there's this pin going on right how to
really meet that threat and maybe this
night could grab here on the next turn
so that's why we're not seeing that sort
of capture go on pawn takes pawn because
of the pressure that could be placed on
this d2 night instead Bishop takes
Knight Queen takes bishop and only now a
pawn takes pawn and rook on e to d8 a
very very sharp move looking to well
first and foremost placing the knight in
a pin but black is now getting ready to
place this Queen very deep in the white
position where she really radiates she
really shows herself quite well placing
this hitting this Knight again and also
hitting this a five pawn so white simply
gets out of that pin right away and
Queen c3 hits this night for a second
time we can play this nice regrouping
type of move moving it to its most
natural square classical square on f3
and after Queen takes pawn we see Bishop
to b3 this is an interesting move you
know with this this tension between
these two pawns at me you may very well
be tempted as white to maybe just grab
this pawn here but Fischer is starting
to look at this King here and how this
point on f7 this pawn on f7 is a bit
vulnerable you know if you could attack
it once and you know maybe even a second
time that starts to be an issue and sure
enough in this game pressure starts to
mount against the
Pond right here on f7 so let's start out
first with Bishop b3 places that pawn in
a pin and after pawn takes pawn we have
Queen to f4 so this pawn is hit twice
some calculation was of course needed
with this sequence of moves Bishop b3
Queen F for what calculation exactly
well yeah you got to know how to cope
with this move here of course you know
normally you know if there weren't any
tactics in this position the c4 move
would just you know slam a door in this
bishops face but we could just capture
like this and then the rook is there to
just come to the seventh rank and cause
some more problems for blacks so Queen
f4 is played this move is out of the out
of the question and now we have rook d7
adding a supporter ninety-five attacking
the rook and the pond so we're just
piling up on f7 at this point the Queen
come back Queen comes back to defend f7
indirectly and place the knight in a pin
against the Queen and now we have rook B
to d1 this is a very important point in
the game we can't just make any rook
move you know this rook on e1 is
contributing in some way to the position
it's watching over for this rook it's
only intention previously was to watch
over a bishop that was on b2 it has
finished its its duty in doing that so
it's time to get that rook involved so
that's why we're seeing B 2 D 1 and
after rook to e7 we have a a series of
exchanges occurring on f7 and we quickly
arrive at an endgame position which is
unbalanced we have these two pawns which
are together they're connected passed
pawns and we end up having an unbalanced
position where Fischer is able to show
some really good technique in bringing
the point home Bishop takes pawn rook
takes Bishop so a series of exchanges
and at this point Bishop takes pawn here
if King takes Knight we just have rook
check and grab the bishop so taking on
e4 first will allow white or will allow
black
to gain additional material prior to
grabbing on f7 so Bishop takes rook
takes King takes and now rook on the 7th
giving a check and King to f6 so
essentially what you want to do as white
in this position is restrain these guys
from pressing forward so ideally the the
real came here not to just check but it
really wants to get to this b7 Square
once you get behind these pawns to
prevent them from pressing forward so
rook b7 rook check King h2 Bishop d6
check g3 and now b4 so finally the
threat rook takes up b5 was met and now
what do we do with the endgame we get
our kings involved King G to h5 I'm not
quite sure what that does maybe just you
know prevents this g4 move from coming
about it's really difficult to suggest
good moves for black in this position
because these white rooks are placed
very well they're really stopping the
white pawns from advancing neither move
could come about without the loss of
material for black
so just rook b6 really just trying to
tie black up as best you can the bishop
is now pin so rook moves there to defend
King f3 King back to get out of the pin
kingi to this rook is lacking squares it
really could only go to e or excuse me
d5 2 to still be in direct contact with
the bishop in f4 we have a three versus
two majority so we got to get these
three pawns rolling so that's why we're
seeing this advancement f4 we're going
to see g4 as well in the meantime look
at black 2 not a whole lot in fact this
rook right here doesn't have any
reasonable moves any moves with result
in the loss of material so black has to
resort to this sort of pawn move black
is very close to just being in zoogs
wang so i guess i mean i guess there
could be a move like bishop back here
but really nothing nothing concrete is
coming about with the black
moves here so g6g for we have the
exchange of pawns and now g5 looking to
just maybe just grab the last of the
white pawns maybe after something like
this maybe if black could grab this pawn
here at some point you know of course
this Bishop is hanging but ideally what
black would like to do in this position
is really just trade all the white pawns
and just get into an ending where it's
the rook and Bishop versus the two white
rooks that's a much more drawable sort
of position so in response to g5 Fischer
wants to maintain those pawns on the
boards that's why we see f5 Bishop to e5
preventing this rook from maybe making
use of e6000 and if the King comes here
that would actually run into mate rook
to e6
so the Bishop to e5 move stops the rook
from accessing these squares here so
rook b5 pins this pawn to the rook which
allows this move right here rook takes
pawn and what black is pretty much in a
bind right here the move played was King
to f6 allowing rook takes pawn but there
really wasn't a way to avoid it for
example if you move this bishop we could
see rook check King here that's really
the only move right because you go here
you get mated and if you go here you get
mated so this is the only this is the
only move from this position and
actually what we would see from here is
a move like King to d3 notice how we
don't have to worry about this
discovered check the bishop could go
wherever at once we have all our pieces
on light squares this guy is not going
to bother us at all so the King kind of
just shift over and alleviate this rooks
duty of watching over this pawn from
advancing so this can come to c2 and
watch over this pawns advancement and in
the meantime this rook could eventually
you know come over in this direction and
maybe threaten to come here at some
point maybe get ready to press forward
on f6 so things like that are in the air
if black isn't careful so considering
those sorts of ideas that white
as black is opting to just allow this
sort of capture to occur so King f6 rook
grabs grabs the pawn and out Bishop to
d4 grabbing the rook going into this
endgame is simply lost pawn here rook
here pawn here and the king is just
going to sneak over here and just grab
this pawn next these two pawns right
here are connected so it's a big asset
in almost all pawn endings so this
ending right here would be no exception
so we don't see that sort of exchange
after rook takes pawn simply Bishop D D
for white throws in a check here King to
e5 and now a sharp move right here by
Fisher King to f3 threatening mate
there's no time to grab this rook
because of rookie six so how to meet
that the rook simply retreats allowing
the King to make use of d5 in the event
of a check and now we white offers these
rook exchanges this is a good strategy
if you're up material offer some
exchanges so that's what we have with
this sequence of moves and once these
rooks are on this position right here
now we have this possibility where the
rook had come to g6 getting ready to
grab him and then it's just going to be
bad news for black so finishing up we
have King d5 the rook grabs the pond
Bishop e5 f six pins the bishop to the
king and after King to d4 we have rook
to b1 and from this position black
resigns and for good reason how to
really meet this threat right here where
the rook is getting ready to just check
the King and then grab the rook there's
really no convenient way to do it
because this King unfortunately from
this position is tied down to having to
defend this Bishop here so if something
like this occurs just showing you one
variation if Bishop takes pawn we could
simply see you know really just pick
your favorite variation this would be
one of them rook takes King here we
could just simply grab this pawn and
then grab this rook and this is going to
be a one game so as it went in this game
after
after King to d4 and rook to b1 Spassky
ends up resigning so that's all for this
video I hope you're able to take
something away from it take care bye